notre pièce à conviction un iphone 4
dont le bouton d'allumage fait des
fouilles
le lieu du crime 3 apple store ceux de
montréal brossard et québec
nous sommes allés au genius bar de
chacun des établissements avec une
caméra cachée
chaque fois voici ce qu'on nous a
répondu
je suis
j'allais pas faire fonctionner vos dons
la solution dans ce cas ci le boudin
j'ai de la lema
fait le même coup que son cul
lens auxerre
est ce bien vrai parce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose
oui certainement c'est un problème très
commun martin masse est propriétaire de
zone accroc une boutique qui depuis 15
ans se spécialise dans la réparation
d'appareils électroniques
donc on va remplacer le bouton
d'allumage ça va nous prendre une
trentaine de minutes
combien ça va être 60 dollars je voulais
sont les parfaits certainement
g
et voilà travail terminé